the struggles of CNN that is the subject
of tonight's waters words the Fox News
Channel used to compete against CNN but
not anymore take a look at the basic
cable ratings for the first quarter of
2018 Fox News number one MSNBC number
two CNN seven CNN's being beaten by
channels like HGTV Investigation
Discovery and Nickelodeon what happened
let's take a look here the story CNN has
decided to own recently a missing plane
what it was hijacking or terrorism or
mechanical failure or pilot error but
what if it was something fully that we
don't really understand a lot of people
have been asking about black holes a
fired possibly drunk Trump hanger owner
talking to you yeah I have smelled
alcohol on your breath well I didn't
drink you haven't had a drink so that's
not know so I just because it is the
talk out there again I know it's awkward
let me just get give you the question
category anything else no no no besides
my meds okay antidepressants is that
okay no I mean I'm not I'm good I'm just
trying to understand look today and a
porn star stormy Daniels had the
president's number it sure seems that
way
stormy Daniels stormy Daniels stormy
Danielle stormy Daniels it's stormy
Daniels stormy Daniels the reason he
can't engage with stormy Daniels is
because she's got his number but how
does that square with CNN's new promo
that casts the network as a paragon of
journalistic credibility this is an
apple some people might try to tell you
that it's a banana
they might scream banana banana
banana over and over and over again he
might put banana in all caps
he might even start to believe that this
is a banana but it's not so CNN's in the
truth-telling business
what about CNN's fake news story about
Trump jr. coordinating with WikiLeaks or
CNN's fake video of Trump feeding fish
in Japan or CNN's fake news story about
commis testimony or CNN's fake news
story about scaramouche II and the
Russians which was redacted and led to
three people resigning and CNN prime
time has become almost unwatchable
here's why that was an excuse look they
got the permit and can I finish Simone
we just shut up for a minute and let me
even know the law he's a thug your
friend you hate it so much just a week
inside that's your substantive argument
to me Rick Wilson who backed every loose
now this type of mayhem completely
undercuts CNN's so-called identity as a
mature straight news network
there are great journalists at the
network don't get me wrong I'm just not
going to name them because I don't know
if they take that as a compliment coming
from me but the bottom line is the
network is filled with Trump hating
tabloid food fights you don't believe me
look at how much time was devoted to
stormy Daniels compared to how much time
was devoted to the spending bill a
spending bill obviously has much more
impact on the lives of Americans than
gossip but maybe CNN is just trying to
hold people's attention while they're
waiting for their flight at the airport
or maybe they're just throwing Hail
Marys because they're in LA
place